معنى الان من مراسله الجزيره
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود ارحب بكم وابدا
معك
كيف تتعامل موسكو مع الانباء الوارده من
كييف الحديث الان عن البدء الهجوم المضاد
وان كانت تكتم حول مساره وايضا حول خريطه
تقدمه هو سيد الموقف
نعم قبل اعلان زيلينسكي ببدء الهجوم
المضاد كان هناك اعلان من الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذي اكد انه يقينا هذا
الهجوم بدا وهذا يمكن التثبت منه لناحيه
الهجمات المكثفه التي تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه على عدد من المحاور وايضا
استخدام
المسماه بوتين يومها بالمخزون الاستراتيجي
لهذا السلاح واكد ان كل هذه الهجمات يتم
صدها ازدهار لنفهم ما جرى في الايام
الماضيه والامر والمشهد المرتبط بالهجوم
المضاد في الخامس من حزيران يونيو اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع عن استهدافات مكثفه للقوات
الاوكرانيه وهجمات متعدده على محور جنوب
دنيتك حيث نتواجد نحن وتحديدا عند جبهتين
اساسيتين هما جبهه اوغليدار وجبهه مارينكا
يومها توجهنا الى تلك الجبهه جبهه مارينكا
وشاهدنا بام العين التعزيزات العسكريه
الروسيه المكثفه على تلك الجبهه والدفع
بهذه التعزيزات باتجاهتين الجبهتين وايضا
شاهدنا القصف المتبادل من قبل القوات
الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه هذا قراه
المحللون العسكريون في روسيا على انه
اعلان لبدء هذا الهجوم المضاد ثم توالت
الهجمات على عدد من المحاور واخيرا اتى
الاعلان على لسان الرئيس الاوكراني ببدا
هذا الهجوم المضاد ما الذي يجري ميدانيا
يمكن القول ان هذا الخط الذي يبدا في
وصولا الى مقاطعه
هذه المناطق كلها تشهد معارك محتدمه
اكثرها احتداما في مقاطعه
هناك قتال مستعر تؤكد القوات الروسيه انها
تصد كل الهجمات الاوكرانيه كما اشرنا جبهه
اوغليدار وجبهه مارينكا في جنوب مدينه
دنيتك ايضا
باتجاه المناطق الواقعه تحت سيطره سيطره
القوات الروسيه جبهه اخرى يتم الحديث عنها
بعد تفجير سادكه خوفك هي مقاطعه خرسون
اليوم يدلل الخبراء العسكريون على انها
ستكون جبهه جراء التحركات للقوات
الاوكرانيه والتحشيد لهذه القوات عند ضفت
نهر وايضا يقولون ان هذا الامر مرتبط بقصف
على الجبهه التي على الجهه التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه وايضا يقولون ان
ويبررون هذا الامر بالاستهداف لصديقه
خوفكا وازاله كل التحصينات التي كانت
القوات الروسيه قد وضعتها على هذه الضفه